Let's look at the solution for our speed doubling quiz. This is a period of
36 years. If speed doubles every two years, that means that
the speed has doubled 18 times. So, we have 2 to the 18th
times 380. And if you multiply this out, it
amounts to about 99 million kilometers per hour and change.
In reality, the speed record for trains has not even doubled between
1971 and 2007. The fastest thing that humankind ever built
is the Voyager one probe. And its top speed was 62,000 kilimeters per hour.
If trains, since 197, followed speed doubling of processors,
trains should have moved this fast by 1996.
So, as you can see, processors are one of
those rare things that have observed speed doubling
continuously for many years and are still doing that.